yeah good so let's go ahead and today we
going to talk about linear regression or
Le squares method
you uh you have seen it
several several
times
so
linear linear
regression and to start with I have I
have here the the picture that we have
seen in the in the last lecture in the
last lecture we were dealing with the
problem of what if I did couple of
experiments thousand I measured thousand
thousand data points and now I assume
that all these data points are just a
measurement of one constant value of of
some quantity but the problem is that I
just uh I just have some uh some
measurement measurement noise in the in
the data and what we what we did
basically well we found out that
arithmetic mean is uh is the best
estimator to get closer and closer as
the number of measurements increases to
the to the True Value to the to the one
basically what uh in some other other
perspective what we did and I hope my
drawing will be will be good
here ah nice
almost basically what we what we what we
did based on this data we tried to get
the histogram in some form and uh
actually fit uh fit uh a
distribution fit a normal gausian
distribution to this so okay well it's
just my my bad drawing but uh if the
distribution looks like this
distribution only has these two
parameters mean and standard
deviation so for example here we would
we would estimate that our that the that
this uh value of this of this constant
is slightly slightly below below it it's
true value and we would even reflect the
uncertainty that we that we have because
our measurements are telling us each
time something
else uh today the picture will will
change just just
slightly let me do the same color code
if I can find the
maybe this is blue so
today the the setup is is is almost is
almost same we performed couple of
couple of experiments maybe this time we
would we would uh know some uh some
difference between these experiments
which we would which would quantify in
the in the variable X practical example
uh which you will also see in your
exercises we will take a couple of
measurements with different temperatures
some gas and uh and we will observe what
are the what are the pressures how would
the how would the the the pressure
change so for so for let's say
temperatures some independent variable X
we do a couple of measurements and we we
record the corresponding
corresponding responses let just let's
just call them call them why and if we
just now compare these these two
pictures well if we just take take this
one and we somehow rotate it and and and
tilt it well we can immediately see that
now our our
task might be really really
similar let's see we are trying to
trying to find again some some mean
value but just this time this mean value
will be a curve that will depend on this
independent variable
yeah and
uh as uh as as I draw this gaam
distribution well we we will again take
all the all the all the possible
measurements and well now this is quite
tricky to visualize but we
can we can draw again some some sort of
a some sort of a mini Goan distribution
that would like that would go along
along this line and will be again again
like like the like the histogram here we
will we will take each of the
measurements into into account and we
will try to find the maximum likelihood
estimate and we already know that this M
maximum likelihood estimate is the same
as Le squares
estimation so far so
good doesn't doesn't maybe remind you of
of uh of anything uh familiar but it
will in a in a second
um how can we how can we en encode this
so
let's say that we have some Kate
observation and our Cate observation
might
be we we had we had something similar in
the in the case of our in the case of
estimation of the of the constant so we
can explain each observation each data
point with some with some model with
some with some prediction and uh
the rest is is the is the uncertainty so
some so some
measurement measurement
noise and
uh we talk about the about the linear
regression so
our or let's put it let's put it this
way so our model our prediction will
be let's have it as as simple as
possible just a line that uh that will
be that will be parameterized by by two
two values so the so the slope of this
of this uh CN line and The abisa
Intercept offset or uh or bias yeah just
to this is like a abisa there there is
maybe double
s or
intercept
offset or bias yeah those are those are
the the names for for this B which is
actually well if our slope is zero then
this would boil down to the estimation
of the of the constant that we that we
saw that we saw last
time okay uh
of course uh our assumptions will will
remain as as in the last week uh that uh
the error so each time we are we are
measuring so if there was no error we
would be
measuring points on this CN line since
there is some error it will it will add
and this eror will be will be gaan
distributed and to
be or normally
distributed uh to be uh really nice well
we have some some uh zero mean so let's
say our sensor is good in in average on
average it gives us the uh the the true
value of what we try to measure and well
we have some some
estimation some estimation noise some
standard deviation of this noise
uh before we do some some mathematics
which you will all all know uh did you
ever wonder why do we why do we call it
regression also in Slovak we say regress
regression means something what does it
mean yeah exactly it means some
deterioration something is going wrong
yeah so why why is it that that we that
we call it that we call it
regression uh
it's just like uh we we inherited some
it somehow from the from the past uh Mr
I guess the name is Galton
no Mr Galton was
doing he was a
biologist something like that and he was
he was doing
uh this this sort of a experiment he
took two groups uh parents and and
children and he measured the the height
so he was then constructing this sort of
a graph like height of a of a
parent and then
the height of of a child
of course probably some
grownup and uh if you if you are about
to do do some do some prediction what
what would you expect what is the what
is the
correlation the tall parents have what
tall children or small children
or really tall yeah exactly and the
small parents or short parents would
have would have small small children so
you would expect to see something like Y
is equal to to X sort of sort of
curve but Mr Galton found found
something something like
this it was the the real data if we when
when he when he plotted them he found
there is there is some there is some
deviation he found out that okay if we
have a tall parents then their children
are are are SL slightly slightly shorter
and if we have a small small parents
then then their then their children
children are SL slightly taller than
than than expected and uh and he
concluded that okay the height of the
people of the population is turning
towards the mean and what he said like
this uh the the height of the of
the of the children is regressing so
descending asob said regressing towards
the towards the
mean towards the mean or towards the
average yeah
and just because he he used this word
regress then then that's that's why we
we use linear
regression that was for the fun
historical historical facts let's do
some let's do some uh some math
so of course if we if we now
take our our data points what are our
our data points so let's start with this
simple example that we always have some
Tuple some some pair of uh of the in the
Kate experim expent we had this
temperature and we measured this this
pressure so we have some in independent
and dependent variable this is
repeating
from similarly as as we did did last
time so let's say we have uh couple
capital capital N number of
measurements and this K is our is our
iterator
so our task is of course to find what
are the values of A and
B we know we can pose this as a
optimization problem it's a standard
standardly
squares uh so let's let's do it um for
some very good reason reasons we will
put this one half uh in the as a
multiplier of our objective
function and what can we do now well we
take
a sum of squares of the deviations of of
what of our data points from the mean
that we are that we are trying to trying
to
find or in other words we can
already already like in what we have
assumed assumed here to
be yeah to be our to be our
model so - A
XK minus
BK good so how do we find a and
b what are your suggestions
we we
differentiate differentiate this
objective function with respect
to X is given x x are
numbers A and B exactly yeah so we want
that this uh this function
differentiated with respect to a is zero
and uh and with respect to B so let's do
the part with respect to
a what do we
get okay maybe I'll just start okay we
have a constant of one half so let's
just keep this constant here
we have a summation so deriv derivative
of a sum is a sum of the derivatives so
the sum
is is staying with us and
then we have a quadratic
function we can
multiply the brackets within
itself
simp why canot we just say like what is
the derivative of anything to the power
of
two yeah so two times this bracket
yeah and what we are missing the
derivative of the interior of this of
this bracket
right which
is
x- XK minus XK
exactly
okay so let's let's continue and let's
do the the derivative with respect to B
that might be even simpler
so nothing will will change until until
this point right it's the same same
expression 1 12 sum of K from 1 to n 2 *
y k - a x k - B and then derivative
of of the B will
be minus one
exactly okay
so let's somehow start to start to work
with with this
um can canel
exactly two doesn't depend on the on the
K so these guys are
gone we can also also cancel this one
what do you
say it's it's it's just the just the
constant yes so let's uh let's then
start working on if this is equation one
this is equation two let's maybe take
equation two first looks looks slightly
slightly
simpler um so we have zero is 0 is equal
2 now what do we have here we have the
sum of YK sum of these guys sum of of
these guys yeah so we can break this
bracket break this bracket into
individual
sums good
yeah so this will be the this will be
just the just the just the first first
sum uh yeah sum of sum of Y case um with
the second sum I see there is a minus
and there is also this common common
factor common uh common parameter
a so I we can we can Factor it out in
front of the in front of the
sum and
uh with the last guy we have seen it
here already several times we can do a
another trick which will involve uh the
fact that we do not have to write the
sum again how will it look
like right
everybody sees why this is n * B right
I'm
suming minus B minus B again minus B
again minus n * n *
B
[Music]
okay can we already already find out so
what will be our estimate of the of the
B it's almost it's almost separated from
from our our expression
oh let's let's do
that this is
n
yes so let's do that
uh what do we get we just take the minus
MB to the right right hand side right
hand left hand side sorry left hand side
and we divide by
n so we get let's do it in this way
1 / n with the first sum and then we get
- A * 1 / n i don't put them together
just you will see in in a second
why of
XK oh makes sense
good so if I know my data y I know my
data X I can already calculate here
something I still don't know the value
of uh value of a but at least I have I
have this relation
and again 1 /
n yeah oh
that's a yes it's a a to you okay thanks
yeah yeah tell me tell me let me know if
this is unreadable I'm
happy now you will say this it looks
like some other letter um
okay
but let's see these
Expressions what are they
solved what are these Expressions how
can we how can we write it or what they
are
I sum several numbers n of them and I
divide them by the by the number of the
sums of by the number of of the guys I
have arithmetic there are arithmetic
means right the arithmetic mean it's
it's all over the place Place once you
see it you you cannot unsee it so we can
even say okay this offset
bias abisa intercept
is is is is relatively simple well I
just I just take I just take my my data
X and Y I calculate their means and I
have this nice and nice and neat uh
relationship
good it
uh it might turn out that this will be
similar for
our for
[Music]
our our parameter parameter a let's
let's see let's let's let's try let's
try to see whether we whether we get
something similar
so the only complication and the
difference from the from the previous
equation is that everything here is
multiplied by
XK of course
to to make it make it easier we can just
uh just cancel this minus same same
thing as as we did with the minus minus
one
here and let's then try to try to
rewrite this so need to get zero being
equal to what we want to solve it for a
yes so can we just let the ENT bra
disappear because there's multiplication
between two brackets either one or the
other is
zero one or the other is zero yeah so
because it's equal to zero but there is
a
sum I'm not sure
well I mean we have n n of these
multiplications
uh not sure whether whether it it will
whe whether whether this this will
happen but uh actually we will not not
solve for a we will just make it into
the into some convenient uh convenient
form and uh and then then we will uh
then we will see how how we can how we
can solve it solve it
easily so let's just get it into some
some convenient form and the convenient
form will be just that just that we do
the multiplication between these uh
these two two terms so we definitely
have sum
of YK *
XK
minus the a will be again factored out
so we have minus
a sum from K = to 1 until n of XK
squ and the
last last term will be Min - B
* sum of
XK until n
this is everything with what that that
we will that we will uh do with this
there is no immediate uh immediate mean
but of course we can we can do like uh
we
will divide the whole whole equation
with n we will see again some arithmetic
averages would would appear but let's as
let's observe uh something
something else with with the expression
two with the expression one the the
structure is is kind of kind of similar
we always have
some some uh
actually constant yeah because if we
which which we know we we know we know
this data we can calculate these sums uh
then we have minus a times there
is there is of course the another
uh another sum another coefficient we we
might say so something which we can
easily calculate from the data and the
same goes for the for these last
Expressions
so where I'm where I'm heading to is
what if we just uh just put this into
the form
of NP is equal
to I don't know some nice letter
N which is just uh ax is is equal to B
but I don't want to use the ax is equal
to B because there are already some A's
and and X's so what if we just uh just
turn this expression into the linear
into the form of U linear are algebraic
equations well and then we know what to
do in matl we just write m/n and we are
done we have our we have our variables
variables
P yeah so now comes the
intellectual
uh
stimulation if I say that
our our Vector p is of course the
the parameters A and
B how can we how can we write this down
what will
be what will land where how will the
Matrix M look like how will this this
Vector n look
like what do you say how would you start
thinking about this
[Music]
first term is the last
Matrix this one or
the the first
term this one no tell me up left right
or hotter
colder we're doing the first first
for example
yes well I mean we will we will
represent both of them in in the in the
Matrix form right I me that mhm the
first term of the first equation this is
first equation right yes okay first term
is zero on the right side okay first
term yeah this
sum exactly yeah so uh we can we can
also also turn it very easily nohead
there are always always minus signs so
let's pretend they they will go to the
to the left hand side so what we are
lefted is left with is uh is This this
term
so sum of y k oops
XK from k equals to one
until until
n then we can either either continue
here or just construct the first row of
the of the of the
Matrix what comes
where the first place isn't the
like secondine think the
equation so we
have sum of x
squared what is left it's not not that
hard to to find out the eight sum of X
case yeah
right so we express this this first
equation a * X sum of x s we have it
here plus b * sum of X will be equal so
we'll have a different sign than than
the sum of YK time
XK
good and now the easier one we started
with the with the more complicated so
the easier one will be how will it go
equation mhm it should be again like the
first part on the left
side on the right side in The Matrix
equation
yes
exactly some
of YK YK then the
first element is sum of XK sum of
[Music]
XK and the last one is n and the last
one is n i mean this one seems to be
like the like the old one out but again
whenever we want we we can we can also
also also transform it into what is n
well it's the sum of ones which goes
from K = to 1 until until n yeah
so if we just want to see also the sum
because we have we have sums sums
everywhere
yeah okay well it's uh it's it's it's uh
it's now quite easy all this m all what
this Matrix contains is our data either
X or well this is only only X and uh and
here we have a on the right hand side we
have a mixture of of y's Y and X's so
our uh Matlab routine will be will be
very easy we just do
this do this uh in inversion of Matrix a
times the times the vector n or we
solved solve this system of linear
equations easy peasy
um
what again isn't X from
why it's just five is 5 squar a
problem yeah good thank thanks very very
good question yeah yeah yeah so this is
this is just this is just data in some
form
um where are we where we are heading to
is uh uh well if we now now have more
parameters these matrices would would
grow and we will get uh more uh more
more sums so we should head and uh try
to make use of the Matrix Vector
notation to to simp simplify this yeah I
already wrote only a few sums today and
my hand is already tired of writing
writing the writing the sums um
one
particular thing that uh that we should
before that uh touch upon is
the is the notion of uh making the
making the
data uh
centered centered or
normalized centered or normalized
[Music]
data so let's imagine
our the our very very same problem let's
say our y hat is equal
to uh let's write it simple just write
just let's write
y our Y is equal to a x +
B what we what we already know well we
already know our best estimate for the
for the B which involve this uh these
means so we already already know that
our B is uh can be nicely expressed as a
a * xar
minus
no
[Music]
plus Mak sense makes
sense
okay me
something ah there is minus right
we have wrong wrong sign
here sorry about
that nothing changes in our in our
narrative I just I just realize it now
that that the somehow the somehow the
the units do not do not agree
uh so let's rewrite it
again the mean of of the Yus a * mean of
x's okay so let's plug this in and see
see what we get uh so a * X
Plus Y Bar minus a
xar h okay it seems that yeah we can we
can make friends of the terms with with
Y and the terms with with X so let's
just put the Y Bar on the on the left
hand
side
and factor out factor out
a right makes
sense
but what does what does this mean
because we have the knowledge of what
our bias bias offset would would would
look like we can actually quite easily
forget about it and what if we just uh
in the very
beginning transformed our data like we
will have let's say like some y Tilda
let's call it subscript subscript
c
and x till the subscript subscript C so
we will take our measurements and sub
subtract uh their mean from them we will
do the same with the with our
independent independent uh variables and
this already means that we that
we
centered uh which spelling to use that
we have a that we Center our data our
our data have uh have what let's do a
let's do some some example let's say our
X or Y doesn't matter is
uh 5 4 3 2 1 yeah so like the
separate separate values
what is the what is the mean of
X so now if we do X centered x
minus
xar too
much x - xar or x - 3 what do we get how
will this this second row read
and I don't know what why did I write it
in the distending form like 543 to1 I
should have gone one two 3 four five
butus
two what does it mean that that it is
centered well we basically remove the
remove the mean from the mean value so
now we
now we shift it if
our if our
data X and Y
would would look like this oops
sorry and we have the mean of X here and
of course the mean of Y here well then
in
our in our centered centered coordinates
uh we'll get well the data data would
would would look the same but there will
be zero here and and zero here basically
we we take this cloud of points and we
shift it somewhere such that in the
center we have the we have the origin we
have the
origin uh we will we will see why why
this uh this transformation is uh is
beneficial of course because now it's
easy we already talked about it somehow
in the in the first lecture uh now we
can directly see okay uh is there
positive or negative negative
correlation should I expect my slope to
be positive or or or negative so if we
now just just take whatever value of of
X let's say we we took a positive one if
we find the corresponding pair which is
positive that would already indicate our
correlation is is is is positive also if
we took the negative value of x we get
Negative value of y yeah it's just very
very simple very simple tricks very
simple things to see yeah imagine you
have here the temperature in the in the
Kelvin yeah from I don't know 250 to 350
and here you have a pressure in the bars
or or pascals it's not that easy to to
see what is the of course we can plot
but with more data it's it's much much
harder so it's not that not that easy
easy to
see
um what what can also also happen oh
what can also happen what can also help
us is to do a another another small
transformation
another small transformation will be
well let's take
our let's take our Center
data
xus okay and let's
now let's now not not only use uh the
the means of these variables but we can
also calculate the standard deviations
yeah we already already know how to do
that and uh okay so let's just expand
slightly left hand side and the and the
right hand side with the standard
deviation of Y divided by standard
deviation of Y yeah we did nothing
nothing bad to the to the equation we
just multiply it it with one in some
form and let's do the same on the right
hand side with the with with the
standard deviation of of
X what's the first part y this one uh
Sigma y divided by Sigma y so it's
standard deviation of Y standard
deviation of of
[Music]
Y in case uh so standard deviation of Y
would be would be what will be the
square Ro T 1 / by nus one yeah that was
the vessel correction and uh we
get sum of y k minus
y y
bar
yeah same for for X yeah just just
replace with the X's so how far how far
the values of one y are spreading from
their from their
mean okay and let's then
do some kind of a some kind of a
shuffling uh we keep the sigma y as the
as the numerator denominators of of the
left hand side here and of this bracket
here with the Sig Sigma X and we
uh divide by one Sigma Y and divide by
by Sigma
X so if we do this 1 - Y Bar ided by
Sigma
Y is equal
to there will be definitely
a there will be x - xar ided Sigma X
X good this is what we this is what we
want for some reason and what we what do
we have
left what do we have left uh so Sigma y
we we we divide it by so we need to have
the sigma y in
the
[Music]
denominator and uh there will be
some y
X okay we we didn't need to divide by by
Sigma X it it just it just stays here
that
was so we just do one
over Sigma
y question is why did we write it in in
this in this form the answer is uh what
we are doing by dividing this centered
variable with its uh standard deviation
we are actually making whatever standard
deviation this variable had we are
making this this new variable which will
which will have let's call it y n and uh
this variable we'll have well zero mean
we already know it because we are we are
centering in yeah we are removing
removing the mean but also this division
would would cause that we have a that we
have a standard standard deviation of
one and this is a way how the same will
will go of course of course for for this
this variable so now we actually uh
actually can can start to even compare
the variables between between itself
yeah yeah imagine this and you will see
it in your in your exercises this is the
pressure which I which I measured the
pressure goes I don't know from one bar
to to 10 bars or we just express it in
pascals yeah so we have 10 to the power
of five 10 to the power power of six
that's quite a quite a large large
spread and now we compare it with some
with some temperature in the in the
Kelvin yeah the spread may be might be
just 100 Kelvin or or 100 degrees so
it's hard hard to compare hard to
actually actually make sense of the of
the of the coefficient of this of this
slope that that we get with this
transformation we we will start to
uh so let's say we have
this this Co
efficient let's call it a n like
the the
a the the the slope which which relates
this this normalized variable
variables this coefficient will will
turn out to be somewhere in in order of
of minus one and one yeah so even in the
situ sitations in the situations where
we will get more and more independent
variables we can very easily start start
to compare uh the strength of the of the
correlations yeah if this coefficient is
closer closer in absolute value to one
It means that this that our measured
variable really uh uh heavily depends on
that on on that particular independent
ver variable you will you will see it in
your in your exercises very very very
very
soon yeah so then this is the this is
the way how
we how we normalize the data let me just
write it
normalized data uh if I talk to other uh
teachers at this University in in this
town in this country in Europe in the
world we all agree that uh just to do
the normalization whatever task you are
doing it does not have to be
identification doesn't have to be
regression can be just control just to
do the normalization saves a ton of of
ton of time and ton of nerves ton of uh
torn torn hairs so normalization is a is
is a key to make to to to make the
data um reasonably
[Music]
shaped views R views normalization or or
standardization in the in the exercises
I guess standardization standardization
is is a is a is a more common term so if
you say normalization is not clear what
what you mean if the normalization makes
the makes the the the variables to have
a zero mean and standard deviation of of
one then we talk about
the
standardized
standardized data
yeah maybe just to just to
recall do I go
back maybe just to recall this is
something similar that we have seen uh
last week uh yeah just just look look
here at our at our expression when we
were trying to derive very end the conf
confidence interval with actually did
the standardization of the of the
estimation error because our uh
statistics key squared works with the
with the with the standardized uh
standardized variables so whatever we
estimate for our for our standard
deviation of the estimation error we
just correct it we just we just uh
standardize it
[Music]
good did I
say
everything so maybe for
your maybe for your uh exercises you
will
also also try to try to Drive some uh
some confidence intervals let's just do
it in
[Music]
a in the simple simple
fashion
uh let's go back where was our lecture
from last
time so where did we where did we end up
ended up last time last time we were
trying to estimate a value of some of
some constant what we what we found was
this estimate Y Bar y y bar head and
by subtracting some particular number
from it adding some particular number
from it we actually uh found out
well uh with the
this and this percent percent
probability this and this person so with
Alpha perc
probability
[Music]
uh in this in this
interval
oops so it's right hand side
it's left hand side
the My True
Value y y bar well it will it will lie
some somewhere there yeah so our
estimate tells us uh
0.95 to 1 12 well so so the true value
of of one lies within within this this
interval and what we what we only only
need for for this is to is to have uh
have couple of ingredients we need the
estimate of a of this uh of this
constant we need
the what we need we need the standard
deviation of the of how this uh estimate
is far from the from the
measurements and we divide by the square
root of the number of measurements and
this is some standard standard
statistical function that we
use well the story is is just the just
the same here if we have a and let's
just now talk only about about this form
that we are trying to trying to estimate
estimate the slope
to make it to make it easy so we have a
estimate
of of a let's say we just did this uh
where was
it m m Over N we just solve this set of
uh linear algebraic
equations what do we need to have now we
subtract
some some some
some standard
[Music]
deviation divide by the square root what
was what was there else the square root
of the key
square quantile of the key Square
distribution
[Music]
and we would say that the true value of
this of this slope
lies lies in this
interval ah key
squared
inverse and how
to how to estimate this uh
uh the standard deviation
[Music]
well if there was not enough square
roots here is another one and this is
the square
root square root of the some of the
deviations of our data with respect
to with respect to our our
model right
we we do the regression we calculate the
predictions of our model now we can
compare it with our data we find how our
model is basically fitting our uh our
data uh
you will you will know this also as
rmsse root mean root mean squared
squared error and we can we can use it
and and and plug it in take into account
how many measurements measurements we
did we can we can say what is the what
is our confidence in the in the value of
the slope that we uh that we achieved
so this is also known as root mean
squared
[Music]
error if you open any uh paper on
statistics machine learning when they
are trying to uh predict something so
they are building a model to predict
some data it will definitely come come
across the rmsse sometimes they have
they they have just msse so the mean
squared
error this should be minus one yeah for
example uh msse but RMS is somehow more
practical because because what uh the
standard deviation lives in the same
world as our as our as our our data
point so we can say okay our our model
is now off by what are we estimating
let's say we are estimating the the
pressure so our model is off by 0.01 bar
yeah so that's how our our predictions
might be might be
[Music]
wrong okay again this was the this was
the heaviest heavy statistic
part of of this lecture and let's now go
and uh and try to try to
simplify simplify this this expressions
with the with the sums and sums and
everything because you know there there
will there will come there will come
time when we not only not only have a oh
let's say one one vector of the of the
data like we measured in the first
experiment second experiment and the end
experiment we might we might start to
see um situations okay we not only
measure temperature we also measure
concentration and we can maybe even uh
use a square of the of the of the
temperature I'm using Square Mika would
already ask since we have square there
wouldn't wouldn't this be a this be a
problem yeah if I want I can I can build
the model let's let's put it in this
way
a
three uh some some temperature squared
and this still will will be a will be a
linear model because it will be linear
in the in the parameters so the model
linear in parameters we can again use
linear linear regression everything will
will work but then doing the squares of
uh sums of T's sums of C's sums of t
squared and sums of T * Y what what were
our our data sums of C * y it's uh going
to uh very easily turn out to be
impractical to always keep the sums so
uh let's just say okay
our our data will come let's say in this
form we have temperature at the first
measurement at the second measurement at
the nth measurement concentration first
second experiment end experiment and so
on and maybe we even have these
uh squares or whatever
uh whatever functions that
we that we might like to add into our
model
[Music]
um well what we what we see in this in
this in this structure so we still we
still have columns which will represent
like each particular variable or maybe
maybe its transformation so we can say h
okay these uh these are still all each
this each of these columns is just the
one instance is just one uh independent
independent variable and well how many
of these variables in general there will
be well we just if we construct this
this model we just have uh one parameter
second parameter third parameter because
we had three independent independent
variables so actually for each each
column each variable or its
transformation we will try to find one
one parameter so if uh let's say n
number or letter P will will tell us how
many of of these of these uh independent
variables we are we are taking taking
into
account right and
uh so if we just transform this example
into
some into some
uh more more General format well we will
have the first variable measured at
first experiment first variable measured
at second experiment first variable
measured at end experiment yeah so we
can combine this structure of having n n
rows which would which where each rows
represent an experiment a measurement
with the with the fact that we have now
couple of these of these independent
variables
no I see pain in in yacob's
face a lot of
pain I only Pro I can at least at this
point I can only promise you that uh at
the end it will be it will be very easy
it just uh it just sound sounds sounds
very hard in the in the beginning so
just uh just bear with me um
Let's uh let's just write this uh for
this for the for the second variable
yeah so we have so if this was
temperature so temperature in first
experiment temperature in second
experiment third fourth fifth and so on
and in the Until the End experiment then
we have concentration concentration in
the first experiment concentration in
second experiment and so on until the
end
experiment and uh what we get here last
is
the be
value or the be variable variable p in
the first experiment variable p in
second experiment variable p in the in
the nth
[Music]
experiment and what we what we get by
this well we basically get the
Matrix we will call it capital
x
uh so just to just to see whether you
are whether you are completely gone for
good for today what is the num what is
the what are the dimensions of this
Matrix number of rows number of
columns n
and
again
almost yeah first row second row am I
writing it in a in in a wrong order like
you are used to okay
um okay for the for the next lecture we
will we will do it in in in the other
other order but U uh we will once we
establish this capital x we will use it
a lot so we we don't need to uh to care
about the exact number
exact exact order of uh what is the what
is the row and and what is the what is
the
column
yeah I give you that yeah the reason why
I'm writing it in this reverse reverse
order is that I care more about this
column coming from the first variable
yeah that's more important than
particular number of experiments we will
very easily uh find examples R you can
tell you about many examples uh that we
have maybe 200
variables and uh well the number of
columns is let's say 16,000 yeah because
those are like the 15 minute
measurements from from one year yeah
something something like that so uh then
the columns are are more important
because they are they are telling about
the uh about the behavior of
particular temperature pressure about
particular destillation column reactor
and stuff like
that
okay
so if
we if we now have this uh now
established this uh this this notation
so what what is our our notation to to
recall
uh if I if we are talking about
the about the lowercase x it is our good
old good old uh data Vector so just one
variable yeah so it's like making making
this Matrix uh thinner like removing all
the all the all the columns all the P
minus one one columns so we are just
left with with one one
column
uh then if
it's I need to establish how I write
capital x and the lowercase x yeah
lowercase x capital capital
x yeah so that's our good old good old
Matrix here uh what is what is
quite uh quite nice that uh well let's
just assume that our Vector of the of
the output variables will remain to be
to be just the just a
vector which
means which means we will just just
measure measure one one quantity
pressure the
composition of a of a distillate from a
distillation column concentration of
some of some
products
so with
this let's just do the slight uh slight
uh practice with the with the vectors
and uh and matrices maybe maybe just
just the
vectors What if I
[Music]
what if I write expression like this and
this is now the now the lowercase
lowercase
x what will this be this be equal
to so it's scalar product yeah scalar
suing let's just uh let's just first uh
rewrite it what does this strange
looking t means what should I do with
the with the vector
xose yeah yeah so yeah that's what does
it mean so you can also do the
pantomim you change
the
mhm so I have this X1
X2 xn and I multiply by X1
X2 until xn
what will I
get just
the X1 squ + X2 square
plus
okay so it's it's a sum so can we
express it as a sum well where
our the numbers which are which are
changing here let's call them case for
some unknown reason oh
[Music]
sorry and how we can express this as a
sum this Square
mhm okay where have we seen some sum of
XK squared
today is this guy here
right how how about we now
transform transform all this all this uh
the whole of this Matrix into this kind
of a need Vector form because well you
would agree that instead
of some from K = 1 until n of x k s it's
quite
neat to to just write xdx X transpose X
right
so what would be your what would be your
guess
for oh no let's let's just do
the let just do the the easy one
so how can we then transform this YK XK
the sum of YK
XK if we already seen this
one
of again we transpose one of
them why transpose
X would that work right it will be the
the same thing as uh let's
say writing y1 here Y2 here YN here and
uh this will of course of course give us
uh y1
x1+ Y 2 X2 and so on until until n
okay what was our so we already know
know what to do with this one what to do
with this one what about these guys here
I have a I have a sum of just X how can
I how can I
represent what what can I do with
the sorry with the vector X or vector y
but let's just start with Vector X and
it will be same for
y so I represented this sum and I want
to use x here as a
vector yeah just do X is a vector so X1
plus so this sum is X1 plus X2 plus and
so on until until
xn yeah there is one one one so if this
if these y's are are the ones yeah we
just
take just so let's do this sort of a
this sort of a one so so that be
it will have this uh this kind of
support so that we know that this is the
m not not Matrix even vector vector of
ones yeah the one with this leg is just
one one one
until until until the same the same
number of elements as as as the X oh
okay
so so we can just just
very very easily now
[Music]
rewrite let me take
this can I do the copy here if I can do
the copy that will be
nice
copy paste oh I'm learning it something
every day yeah so with this with this
knowledge we can we can already try we
can already easily rewrite so what was
it XK squared sum of
them so sum of squares of of
X was this guy yeah the X transpose
X some of the xcape
case is this one here sum of X case in
the second row of this matrix it's just
here where we can we can keep just the
capital N it's capital N not
a a *
B what do we get here in the instead of
sum of YK XK
y transpose X
and for the sum of y's which is we just
have this one uh vector vector of ones
times
y MH
so we already simplified the
calculations of the parameter a and
parameter B which was just a slope with
respect to one independent variable and
this and this bias a natural question
would be well if we can somehow
somehow
find uh a model no this shouldn't have
been T
sorry our our
model let's say let's say in in this
form we take our our M Matrix X
remember you you to you concluded that
that this Matrix X has
n n
elements and its number of of columns
was the same as the as the number of
variables we were we were doing
regression
with it actually has even a special
special name it's it's called a
regor regressor matrix
F uh well the p is of course the vector
of parameters that we are trying to find
out P of
B and Bas basically this uh this y head
well what it is
it what will be what will be the the
dimension of this of this y hat
so this is p *
1 n * one yeah I think Mela was saying
that but completely silent n * one yeah
so for each of the experiments it is
giving us giving us the the the
prediction so of course it's the it's
the
same same size as our as our measured
data which
means we can now say
h let's
pose finding the parameters parameters P
again as optimization problem Le squares
problem and
uh what can we do so minimization one2
that's what we that's what we started
with
yeah so what can we do now to represent
this sum of squares of differences using
our new Vector
notation we don't want to write the sum
so if we didn't want to write the sum
let me get
there well if you didn't want to
write the sum we just took the the
vector and and transposed
it so now I don't want
to don't want to write the sum of y k
minus
y k Hat Time y k minus y k hat yeah this
is a this is noo
so what Can I Do
yed by
one yeah but we want to we want the
multiplication yeah so we have one
vector we have a we have a second vector
or let's
say um we
have one multiplier second second
multiplier
what if I what if I write just this y -
y head
transpose y - y
head what what what will we we get so if
we had X transpose time time x well this
was equal to XK
squared right so from the first Vector
it it takes one XK from the second
Vector it takes second
XK uh second XK so we get the get a
square same will will will go go go on
here so from the first Vector it will
take the error the difference between
the data point and our and our
prediction and we'll multiply it with
the with the prediction of the of the
same experiment and it will sum over the
second experiment third experiment and
so on
so next time we will we will finish this
and now I now I promise yeah we will
plug in this
y uh y head is equal to x * p yeah
that's what we already established and
what we will what we will end up with is
that P will be equal
to some
Matrix some ma Matrix uh
inverted and M and multiply it by
another Matrix so if you if you are
impatient it will it should
already oops sorry
I can tell you this
will uhuh sorry one step
back
yeah it will look some something
something like something like this there
will be one Matrix another uh and
another another Vector you might already
already use try and use this in your in
your exercises we will derive it derive
it next
time any
questions no if you want you can uh you
can refresh uh like your your knowledge
about how do we do the do the transposes
so how if we have a matrix a times
Matrix B and we transpose them what will
be the how will the transpose of the of
the product look like if you don't know
this it's fine we will we will go
through it go through it next
time h b transpose a transpose
yes okay if everybody is nodding then
I'm looking forward for the for the next
lecture no